Pixar is renowned for cramming loads of
Easter eggs and references into their
animations so with inside out on blu-ray
and DVD now I wanted to take a look at
my top 10 Easter eggs in Pixar's 15th
feature film and for those of you who've
been desperately searching for the three
times that director Pete docter says the
Pizza Planet truck appears in the movie
I've got them all here so keep watching
to find out where they are okay kicking
off with number 10
remember the married life montage at the
start of up well that movie was also
directed by inside out Pete docter
and there are several nights nods to it
in this movie they're tricky to spot as
they can be kind of blurred but you can
see several of Carl's ties in a number
of memory balls at headquarters and
Carl's face also pops up in a green
memory ball in the long-term memory
storage area and you can also see Carl
with Ellie in several more memory balls
behind joy sadness and Riley's imaginary
friend Bing bong at number nine where
the young rider jumps between sofas
pretending the lounge floor is covered
in lava take a look at the table and
you'll see a magazine with a cover
featuring collect from ratatouille
moving on to number eight you've
probably noticed the girl in Ronnie's
class wearing a similar top to Sid skull
t-shirt in Toy Story
but according to Pixar one of the boys
in Riley's class is also wearing a
camouflage pattern top that's made up of
Toy Story characters if you look really
carefully you can just see what looks
like t-rex woody and possibly ham and
the bottom of mr. Potato Head oh and the
globe in Riley's classroom also appeared
in the Toy Story movies and we also see
it at the end of this movie in the mind
of Riley's new teacher at number 7 as
well as shout outs to past Pixar movies
inside out includes an Easter Egg
looking forward to Pixar 16th feature
film the good dinosaur a statue that
looks rather like forrest woodbush the
Styracosaurus from the good dinosaur
appears in Riley's memory of her
family's journey to San Francisco and
the family's car rolls into the back of
a dino statue that looks like a nod to
all over the start of the good dinosaur
number six when joy sadness and
bing-bong head into Imaginationland
there's a stack of board games including
one called
find me which features a picture of a
clownfish on the Box a clear shout-out
to Pixar's Finding Nemo and end of that
game is another called dinosaur world a
little nod to the good dinosaur plus
there's a board game named after Pixar
short film for the birds and those same
birds from that short also appeared
during Riley's journey to San Francisco
in at number 5 there are two scenes in
Imaginationland in which first bing-bong
and later joy make a cloud person
disappear into thin air the second time
it happens a police officer tells his
colleague who wants to pursue the
culprit forget it Jake it's cloud town
which is a funny reference to director
Roman Polanski's 1970s movie Chinatown
which starred Jack Nicholson and ended
with Nicholson's private investigator
character being told forget it Jake it's
Chinatown at number 4 the director at
dream productions the place where
Riley's dreams and nightmares are
created gives the order to add the
reality distortion filter to the camera
which is a nod to Apple co-founder and
former Pixar CEO Steve Jobs an original
member of the Apple Mac design team says
that Jobs had a reality distortion field
which basically meant reality was like
[ __ ] in his hands and he could convince
anyone of anything and change their
perception of reality likewise the
reality distortion filter and inside-out
alters what the actors bringing to life
Riley's dream look like at number three
one of the stores that Riley and her mum
walk past in San Francisco is a
locksmith called Krauss which is named
after inside out supervising animator
Shaun Krauss but did you also notice the
poster at the bottom right hand corner
of the store window it says sure locks
for homes special which when you say it
quickly sounds rather like Sherlock
Holmes special but pixel has its own
connection to Sherlock Pixar's chief
creative officer John Lasseter
previously worked on the live-action
film young Sherlock Holmes which was
groundbreaking for his animation of a
fully computer-generated character
- when bing-bong joy and sadness arrived
at dream productions bing-bong points
out a poster for I can fly a dream he
says he loves that poster is a little
nod to Disney's 1953 animated feature
film Peter Pan which Pete docter has
said was an influence on inside-out and
it also happened to feature a song
titled you can fly and the poster
alongside that for the dream I'm falling
for a very long time into a pit is very
reminiscent of the poster that designer
Saul Bass created for Alfred Hitchcock's
movie vertigo and in the top spot at
number 1 director Pete docter said that
Pixar's Easter Egg regular the Pizza
Planet truck appears three times in
inside out but it's really difficult to
spot and he wasn't kidding but I've got
all three appearances here well actually
it appears four times in three scenes it
first appears in one of the memory balls
that rolls along the floor when joy
first sees Riley's imaginary friends
bing-bong the second one pops up as
Riley starts to play ice hockey and then
it appears again for a third time when
anger explodes after Riley falls down
during that same hockey game and the
last time it makes an appearance is when
joy sadness and Bing bong were on the
train of thought in fact Bing bong even
handles it for a moment of course I also
love seeing other Pixar regulars like
a113 which makes an appearance where
Riley runs away from home and the luxo
ball which turns up during Riley's
playtime with Bing bong but what other
Easter eggs and references did you spot
it inside out and which are your
favorites if you enjoyed the movie you
might want to check out my video with 25
dings you probably didn't know about
inside out I really appreciate your
comments shares and likes on my videos
and do subscribe for more of my Easter
egg vids things you didn't know movie
reviews and more thanks for watching and
see you next time you be game movie
lovers
you